Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys,
without our lab coats.
Yeah, we've actually got
these very fashionable
sort of space suit things.
Little bit Babylon Zoo.
They are.
I feel like I should be playing
like a robot the whole time.
Yeah.
Where are we right now?
We're at the metal casting research lab
at Purdue University.
And we're going to be doing
some molten metal pouring
onto this plate.
I'll stop you there.
Not just any metal, right.
I've seen, you know, videos of
molten aluminum being poured
but that melts at 600
degrees C and we're doing
Child's play.
Nothing isn't it, nothing.
You can do that in the back garden.
This is copper melted over 1,085 degrees
and it's going to be pouring
at 1,200 degrees C.
Over 2,00 degrees Fahrenheit.
I think for this one resolution is going
to make this a lot nicer than speed
so we'll film it at 1,000 frames a second
but in 4K.
First we'll get a light on it
and I think after that we'll just let it
we'll expose it to its own glow
so it'll just be, you know,
surreal molten droplets splashing in 4K.
I think it'll be class.
I think it'll be class too.
Yeah.
Well now that we're agreed
on the fact that it'll
be class, let's move on.
They're melted by induction,
so the coil,
electrical coil in the
refractory there that's
creating a 10,000 HTZ
oscillating signal that's
creating Eddy currents in the metal.
Yeah.
And resistibly heating that and melting it
so there's no gas that's burned.
It's a very clean way
to melt things though.
Having a bit of an issue here
What's up?
Basically, I'm pretty scared.
Yeah.
Obviously 1200 degrees hot melting copper
and I've got these to port with
and I'm like trying to practice with it
and by the time I've
like got the grip right
I'm like okay yeah I'm ready
it's already solidified.
You've got to pour it in like
Yeah it's heavy.
Cause it's a thing full of metal
and I've got to grab it
with this and pour it, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not easy cause it's
1200 degrees at the minute
but then as soon as it goes below sort
of, what is it, 1085 then it solidifies
so you've got very few,
very small amount of time
to be able to pour it.
You always forget that about metal
is that when it's liquid it's still metal.
Yeah, it's still heavy.
Here we go.
You want to be up higher, right?
Yep.
Get it in the center too.
Okay.
Ready?
Cool. Got it?
Yep.
Did you get hit?
You alright?
Awesome.
Did you get it?
Yeah.
You got my hands.
Really? No.
You alright?
Yeah.
You can't really push the
button with these things.
How did that go?
It went well.
I didn't chicken out.
It was good aim.
You went really high and it
landed straight on the pan.
I was quite happy with it.
It's quite distracting
and a lot of pressure
when you've got molten copper
at 1200 degrees in your hand
and you like trying to aim it.
Why don't we show off our little splat
that we've got.
That went nice.
I think what we'll do now
for a bit of variation
is repeat the experiment we'll
turn off the lights though
and I'm going to go wide open on this lens
so hopefully we'll just be
illuminated by its red hotness.
Whoo!
Are you alright?
Yeah.
It's gone everywhere.
He did well to get it in focus actually.
The focus that I gave you is about an inch
and you are nailing it.
That's colly.
I love that.
This is one of those things
that I could just watch this all day.
This could be a screensaver for me.
That looked deluxe.
It looked like melted metal rain.
Perfect balls of glowing hot metal falling
and then just splashing.
This is exact same as
water where it just turns
into individual droplets
by the time it hits.
You get loads of lovely splashes.
Very surreal looking.
Yeah except rain doesn't
glow and spread everywhere
and burn people.
You got me.
You got me in the hand.
I was actually aiming to you.
I was like that wasn't
high enough last time.
Yeah keep going, keep going.
Thankfully we didn't crack a lens
and just some skin got burned on my end.
So actually once again
the glowing hot metal
where I get burned where I
get burned and you don't.
I don't know how that keeps happening
Ow!
I was standing next to it pouring it
but to be fair when I was watching
because you were watching the
camera I was pouring it here
and it spread, you know, a good couple
of meters everywhere
like liquid metal pouring
all over the place.
You can probably find balls of it.
Yeah, well hopefully
you enjoyed that video.
Please let us know
if you liked these science lab experiments
cause we can do more.
Feel free to follow us on
Twitter, buy some merch,
and if anyone knows
how to power down Dan please let me know.
He's out of control.
We got a second channel too.
Are you done are you finished?